la ciudad boliviana de Potosí vivió
cortes de carreteras y manifestaciones
en la planta de litio de lippi
impulsados por el com zipo el comité
cívico potosinista cientos de personas
interrumpieron siete vías de acceso
exigiendo obras en la región y la
aprobación del proyecto de ley de
recursos evaporíticos el cual obliga a
que una parte de los beneficios de la
explotación de litio se ha utilizado
para el desarrollo de Potosí la
mentable tratado de generar un tipo de
división Pero aquí están las
organizaciones
estructuradas orgánicamente qué queremos
el desarrollo de nuestro departamento de
Potosí qué queremos el desarrollo de
nuestra región porque como región hemos
ha dado nuestros recursos y lo vamos a
seguir dando nuestro litio el concipo
incluso amenazó con impulsar un paro
total en la ciudad desde la
administración de Luis Arce acusan una
campaña de desinformación por parte de
la oposición para tumbar el ambicioso
proyecto de explotación de litio que
impulsa su gobierno el gobernador de
Potosí buscó llevar tranquilidad y
prometió diálogo con los manifestantes a
la población de uyuni que estén
tranquilos nosotros
en condición de autoridades tanto
municipales como del departamento de
Potosí vamos a reitero redoblar nuestros
esfuerzos para que estos compañeros se
sienten vamos a agotar hasta el último
para que esta movilización pueda ser
levantada para que no podamos
perjudicarnos entre nosotros en enero
pasado el gobierno boliviano concretó un
contrato con empresas chinas para la
extracción de los salares de uyuni y
koipasa donde calculan que existen 21
millones de toneladas de litio lo que
convierte a Potosí en una de las
reservas más grandes del mundo